TO BLOCK OUT THE NOISE AND GET
AFTER IT WE'LL S GOAL.
BYRON AGAIN.
BRENDAN GALLA
TUESDAY.
HIT JENSEN IN THE
GOOD READ BY REBOUND AND A LITTP
N
FIRST.
CAUGHT UP BY LARS ELLER.
THREE-ON-TWO DEVELOPING.
PASS GOES OFF AROWS IT TO THE
MIDDLE, AND THEN THEY THROW IT
TO THE NET AND IT GOES BETWEENNN
THIS FIRSTTHERE,
YOU WOULD THINK.
>> Sergio:BEHIND MONTREAL--
BUT THEY'RE HANGING IN THERE.T .
DANIEL SPRONG.
GREW UP IN
A SCRAMBLING SAMSONOV IS ABLE TO
FREEZE IT.
>> Sergio: ABSOLUTELY GOOD
PLAY.EE ROMS JUMP
UM ON THE PLAY AST AGAIN FOR THE
ANGLE.
RIPS IT OVER THE SHOULDER OF
CAYDEN PRIMEAU, AND IT'SN HERE .
>> Dan: THERE IS>> Dan: REM PITE
BLUE ICE AND IT'S AGAIN AND IT D
DEFENSEMEN USUALLY HAVE YRON.
REBOUND.
ARMIA CAN'T GET THERE IN TIME.
BUT THAT IS GOOD WORK BY JOEL
ARMIA.
>> Sergio:o: CHANCE.
ARMIA HARD WORK.
OUTMUSCLES CARLSON.
GETS IT
SAMSONOV.
ANDERSON.
PENALTY COMING UP TO THE
CAPITALS. GOALPOST.
HE HITUKI.
COLE CAUFIELD WITH HIS FIRST
CAREER POWER-PLAY GOAL AND IT'S.
THEY DON CAN GET A
BUCKET FULL.
WE'LL SEE AS THE THIRD PERIOD C.
THAT GET THE
PUCK BACK, ANDTEMBEAULT.
DANIEL SPRONG RUSHING OFF THAT
RIGHT WING.
BUT HE IS
THINGS WHEN HE WAS YOUNGER.
HERE HE IS IN THE NHL,NG OFF THE
POST.
ARMIA FROM A VERY SHARP ANGLE.
LET IT RIP.OF THE NIGHT.
THIRD OF THE YEAR.
4-3.
WHAT AELY I THINK THEY
MIGHT.
>> Dan: I THINK THAT IS WHAT
IS PLAY.
PLEASE RESET THE CLOCK TO
BIG STOP BY SAMSONOV.
HAD A REALLY GOOD GAME WITH
SUZUKI HERE
SNIVELY TURNED UP A CHANCE FOR
THERE IS NO DAN ABOUT IT.
THEY FOUGHT HARD.
THEY CAME BACK.
THEY HAD PRESSURE IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF MINUTES